wir stecken mitten in einer globalen
gesundheitskrise und zwar bedingt durch
die vielzahl an problemen keine
bakterien also die resistent sind gegen
antibiotika besorgniserregend ist dass
auch die suche nach neuen antibiotika
alles andere als einfach ist deswegen
suchen forschungsteams weltweit
fieberhaft nach alternativen
große hoffnung setzen experten und
expertinnen in eiskalte bakterien
fresser diese so genannten fragen sind
darauf programmiert bakterien zu töten
und das mit einer zerstörerischen kraft
in laborversuchen kommen die bakterien
fressen sogar gegen multiresistente
keime an könnten fragen also die
menschheit tatsächlich vor dem
schlimmsten bewahren klicks um
science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nicht
herzlich willkommen
dieser gegenvorschlag kam übrigens
dutzendweise über whatsapp da habt ihr
übrigens null risiko ein video zu
verpassen also am besten abonnieren und
den wozzeck newsletter abonnieren
bekommt nämlich immer eine nachricht und
ihr könnt super themen vorschlagen der
link ist in der video beschreibung und
kommt noch mal am ende des videos
wir haben erst vor kurzem bei pixum
science fiction über die killer keime
berichtet die sich mittlerweile auf der
ganzen welt breit gemacht haben und das
auch in den entlegensten winkeln dieser
erde beispielsweise im unberührten aktes
boden wurden gene davon gefunden es
scheint also so dass wir menschen den
superkeim schutzlos ausgeliefert sind
und die waffen der medizin immer
stumpfer werden studien zufolge sterben
schon jetzt jährlich weltweit achtung
700.000 menschen an infektionen durch
medikamenten resistente keime
bis 2050 könnte diese zahl auf 10
millionen opfer steigen im jahr
das sagen zumindest hochrechnungen einer
britischen forschungsgruppe voraus eben
klartext hieße dass dann mehr tote durch
resistente erreger als durch
krebserkrankungen das kann man sich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen aber es
gibt immer wieder menschen die an
bakteriellen infektionen sterben und
zwar unter den augen von ärzten die
verzweifelt ein antibiotikum nach dem
anderen verabreichen und das ohne erfolg
die vereinten nationen hatten die
multiresistenten keime schon 2016 als
die größte und dringendste gefahr
überhaupt bezeichnet und so forschen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit mit hochdruck
daran neue waffen gegen die super kaymer
zu entwickeln um noch das schlimmste
abzuwenden bakterien fresser sogenannte
fragen könnten manchen fachleuten
zufolge vielleicht die letzte hoffnung
sein
im biologischen sinne kann man sie als
viren bezeichnen die es allerdings
einzig und allein auf bakterien
abgesehen haben und diese angreifen und
auflösen
in der fachsprache spricht man von luce
ihren fragen sind eigentlich überall es
gibt schätzungen nach denen sie zehnmal
häufiger sind als bakterien und auch in
unserem körper sind ständig fragen zu
finden die wir beispielsweise über
wasser und essen aufnehmen spannt dabei
ist dass fragen wirklich alles andere
als das neue wundermittel sind die
bakterien fresser wurden nämlich schon
vor 100 jahren entdeckt die wirte der
fragen sind bakterien und so können sich
fragen tatsächlich auch lediglich in
bakterienzellen vermehren und eben nicht
allein eine frage besteht einzig und
allein aus seiner dna also seiner
erbsubstanz die sich in einer protein
hülle befindet insgesamt sind fragen
deutlich kleiner als bakterienzellen das
besondere an diesen bakterien fressen
ist dass sie spezifisch sind das
bedeutet dass ein fahrer nur bakterien
mit entsprechender 10 oberfläche
angreifen kann das passiert nach dem
sogenannten schlüssel schloss prinzip
ein wesentlicher pluspunkt ganz im
gegenteil zu antibiotika die zwar
spezifisch gegen bestimmte bakterien
sein können aber eben nicht spezifisch
gegen eine bestimmte bakterienarten oder
bakterien stämme und der überfall eines
fragen auf ein bakterium ist wirklich
nicht ohne der frage schießt nämlich
eiskalt sein erbmaterial in das
bakterium dieses wird dadurch gezwungen
neue generationen anfragen herzustellen
bis die bakterienzelle dann voll ist mit
jungen farben und letztendlich platzt
die vielen neuen fragen ziehen dann
ebenfalls los und weitere
bakterienzellen an zu fallen ähnlich wie
bei einem antibiotikum kann es passieren
dass einzelne bakterienzellen eine
resistenz gegen den spezifischen fragen
entwickeln doch das lassen sich die
frage nicht gefallen und entwickeln
ebenfalls sogenannte mutationen diese
versetzen sie dann in die lager auch die
eigentlich resistenten bakterien
anzugreifen wenn somit alle ziel
bakterien abgetötet sind zerfällt der
frage selbst in seine bestandteile da es
ihm an nahrung fehlt der menschliche
organismus
ist in der lage die reste der bakterien
fresser zu verstoffwechseln und das
problem ist gelöst und es gibt einen
weiteren enormen vorteil der bakterien
fresser im vergleich zu antibiotika denn
es gibt wohl nur wenige nebenwirkungen
wie etwa allergien
doch zu 100 prozent sicher sind die
fangen wir auch nicht den studien
konnten zeigen dass sie ungeahnte
fähigkeiten haben die uns langfristig
gesehen auch schaden könnten
offensichtlich sind sie wohl in der lage
unter gewissen umständen resistenzen auf
bakterien zu übertragen
dabei dienen sie als eine art
informationswege das genetische vorlagen
eines bakteriums in die neu befallenen
bakterien mit einbringt diese waren dann
im experiment unempfindlich gegen
antibiotika wirkstoffe fatal die fragen
hatten die bakterien also nicht zerstört
sondern im gegenteil sie hatten sie
sogar noch gefährlicher werden lassen
gen analysen könnten dieses risiko
allerdings senken zusammengefasst
könnten die meisten ihrer eigenschaften
die fragen dennoch zu einer wirklich
guten alternative zu antibiotika machen
weltweit laufen dazu viele experimente
in einigen konnten die bakterien fresser
zeigen dass sie sogar gegen
multiresistente bakterien ankommen im
übrigen gilt eine fragen und
antibiotikum therapie schließen sich
nicht grundsätzlich gegenseitig aus
sondern können auch nebeneinander
angewendet werden super daran ist
einfach dass fragen unbegrenzt zur
verfügung stehen und zwar in natürlichen
systemen wegen der spezifität die ich ja
schon angesprochen hatte ist es dann
notwendig die geeigneten fragen gegen
den bestimmten krankheitserreger zu
finden wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler nehmen dafür
beispielsweise proben aus klärwasser
dort gibt es besonders viele fragen
schätzungen zufolge bis zu 100 millionen
verschiedene arten in nur einem
millimeter erfolgversprechend sind
fragen bei der behandlung von
bakteriellen infektionen spannend nicht
nur für chronisch lungenkranke
brandverletzte sondern auch für
diabetiker die probleme mit offenen
wunden haben doch trotz der viel
versprechenden eigenschaften der fragen
werden sie in deutschland bzw
in westeuropa und den usa bisher nicht
als therapiemittel eingesetzt ganz
anders als in georgien wo dieser
behandlungsansatz schon lange etabliert
ist doch bisher gibt es bei uns trotz
intensiver forschungsbemühungen keine
studien die die sicherheit und
wirksamkeit der fragen sicher beweisen
können 2017
das bundesforschungsministerium immerhin
die ersten klinischen studien mit
bakteriophagen in deutschland genehmigt
doch es gibt zudem auch bürokratische
hürden denn rechtlich ist hier noch viel
zu tun damit fragen innerhalb der eu
zugelassen werden könnten handelt es
sich um medikamente impfstoffe oder ist
es sogar eine komplett neue klasse an
medizinischen produkten muss vielleicht
sogar jedes einzelne fragen medikament
das zusammengemischt wird zugelassen
werden oder ist eine generelle zulassung
möglich bis in deutschland offiziell
fragen mittel eingesetzt werden dürfen
brauchen wir wohl noch etwas geduld
dabei sollten sich die behörden
allerdings etwas sputen denn das
resistenz problem wird immer größer
werden doch erst wenn die bürokratie
geklärt ist könnten die fragen im kampf
gegen superkeime mitmischen und es sind
nicht wenige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die sich ganz sicher
sind dass fragen uns aus der globalen
krise retten könnten der krise der
multiresistenten bakterien die die
menschheit bedroht für dieses video mit
noch mehr infos hier draufklicken und
hier geht es zur whatsapp community
anschauen das video und abonnieren und
natürlich dem konzept newsletter bis
dann bleibt dran